[Music]
i'm really scared right now this cake
because it's so hot in here like all the
frosting is like can you turn up the ac
it's on max i'm living in a nightmare
[Music]
hey guys it's katie and i love cooking
on a budget and today we are celebrating
tasty's fifth birthday we
made it and what better way to celebrate
than to get a cake unfortunately the
cake i want is this rainbow explosion
cake that's from the flower shop in new
york city and it is 150
we just we don't have that kind of money
so
i'm going to show you today how to make
a version of that cake for only twenty
dollars i already got my groceries it
took a lot of time i had to go to
multiple stores but it was totally worth
it because the total came out to twenty
dollars and seventeen cents and i'm only
going to be using one pantry staple
freebie today which is salt so with all
that said why don't we get into it and
we'll see how this turns out let's hope
it's a piece of cake
good thing chris isn't here to hear that
so first thing we're going to do is make
a very basic vanilla cake we're going to
start out with some all-purpose flour
some baking powder and my freebie salt
and then you'll whisk that together all
right that looks good now we're gonna
move on to our wet ingredients so you
need a much bigger bowl for this we're
gonna combine a lot of butter
a lot three sticks and some sugar
and then you're gonna mix this for about
five to six minutes until it's super
light and fluffy now we're gonna add our
eggs i've let these come up to room
temperature this way it doesn't break
our batter when we add it in we're gonna
add these one at a time so we can make
sure they get incorporated evenly last
thing we're going to add is a little
vanilla extract
mix that in
now we're going to add some milk and
alternate it with our dry ingredients
and mix those together and this helps to
make sure you don't over beat your
batter when you over beat your batter
you get a dense tough cake and when
you're finished you should get this
really silky thick batter oh it looks so
pretty now this is a rainbow cake it has
six layers so we need to make all the
colors of the rainbow with this batter
i'm gonna take six bowls
and i didn't have all matching six
so we got that guys i'm gonna take a cup
and divide the batter evenly between all
the bowls now we'll add some food
coloring the original cake has like this
neon rainbow we did not have the money
for neon so we just kind of have your
primary colors here we're gonna end up
making red orange yellow green blue and
purple now i have got six of these six
inch cake pans i'm gonna spray them with
a little bit of cooking spray then we'll
add
each of our batter bowls to the pan
and then just pat it down to make it
even out and repeat with the other
colors
[Music]
our cakes are ready to go in the oven
we're gonna bake them at 350 degrees for
about 15 to 20 minutes or until you can
stick a toothpick in it and nothing
comes out okay let's go do it while the
cakes are baking we're gonna make a
vanilla simple syrup first we're gonna
add some sugar
water
and vanilla extract we're gonna put this
over medium-high heat and bring it to a
boil once it's out of boil remove it
from the heat and put it in a heat proof
container
we're gonna use this simple syrup later
to help moisten our cake and give it
more flavor all right so we're gonna
make a cream cheese frosting we're gonna
get started with a bunch of cream cheese
and some butter this recipe has a lot of
butter everything that tastes good has a
lot of butter all right and then we're
gonna mix these two together until
they're super light and fluffy that
looks great so now we're gonna add a
little bit of vanilla extract
okay this next part is gonna seem a
little insane
but we're gonna add a ton of powdered
sugar to this we're gonna sift it in
this way we get a nice smooth frosting
and not a bunch of clubs and this is
going to take a while this is going to
take longer than it is to make the cake
great once you sift that in we're going
to mix it up we're just going to do this
in batches cheer those slaves ring one
ding ding dangle and do
yes she's pretty i'm gonna go put her in
a bag and then we're gonna get her cakes
prepped and then we're close to assembly
we're kind of close
i'm getting ahead of myself let's go get
our cakes all right i got my little
babies here and they have been cooling
on a cooling rack for about 15 minutes
so now i'm gonna take that simple syrup
we made earlier and i'm gonna brush it
on the top this is gonna help keep these
cakes moist especially when you're on a
budget doing something like this really
helps upgrade your cake so next thing
we're going to do is take our cake and
any color except the red and place it on
a cutting board i'm going to take a 2
inch round cookie cutter and we're going
to place that right in the center of our
cake and you're just gonna press down
and then you lift it up sometimes a
piece of the cake comes out and that's
great other times it does not and there
we go a perfect hole in the center of
our cake you're just gonna repeat this
with the remaining colors except for red
now that all of the holes are out of our
cake and we have these whole cakes we
are going to assemble them i'm just
going to put a little bit of
frosting down to make sure
that holds my cake and we're going to
start with purple and then we'll just
add our frosting just pipe that right in
so then after purple we're going to add
the blue
[Music]
all this stuff coming out the sides
that's totally fine because we're gonna
use that to make our crumb coat so to
make the crumb coat i'm just gonna take
an offset spatula like this guy and the
crumb coat just needs to be a very thin
coat and it's okay if there's crumbs
getting in it because that's why it's a
crumb coat it's a protective layer
you're putting around your cake so when
you do your actual frosting it's gonna
not get crumbs in it chris i'm really
scared right now this cake because it's
so hot in here like all the frosting is
like can you turn up the ac it's on max
i'm living in a nightmare if something
looks like it's about to fail don't
freak out just keep going
[Music]
all right i think this is as good and
straight as i'm gonna get it i'm gonna
go put it in the freezer so that it can
start to solidify and then we can do a
real frosting on this wish me luck
okay i did a really dumb thing
in my haste to
get this from not falling over i did the
crumb coat and put on the top before i
filled it with sprinkles which is the
most important part all right so i'm
gonna try to carefully take the top off
and then we will fill it
so just gonna carefully
remove the top
of this
okay like a little hat
and then i have a bunch of sprinkles
here the sprinkles were the most
expensive part of this whole cake
they're very expensive so i'm gonna
spoon this in
gently just guide it can't believe i
forgot this
what a sad explosion cake it would have
been filled to the very top
great and then we're gonna place our red
guy right back on top everyone makes
mistakes while baking and you just have
to keep it together try not to cry so
first thing i'm gonna do is just grab
frosting
and put it all around the cake
all right so now that we've really
covered the cake we're gonna start to
smooth things out here
and this is where you can kind of work
out some of those
problem areas you know those troubled
areas hide it a little bit
now i'm in no way a professional baker
so
i'm doing the best i can here
[Music]
all right i think we're done the great
thing about this cake is it doesn't have
to be perfect it's okay if you're seeing
through it a little bit because the next
thing we're going to do is cover it in
sprinkles i have a bucket here and it is
going to catch any excess sprinkles
because this is a very messy part of
doing this cake i'm going to take some
of my hand
oh my gosh
okay i am not good at this
[Music]
you're not supposed to go from the top
down should i be going from the top down
both seem difficult
[Music]
i'm getting better look at that that was
better
[Music]
i did it i didn't think that i would get
to the end of this day
but i did
okay i'm gonna go put this on a
beautiful pedestal and admire my work
and maybe cut a slice for chris to try
look at my cake whoa
it's insane looking how much do you
think it cost me i would say at least a
hundred million i'm very proud of myself
it cost only 20 dollars to make i think
it looks very similar to the one we were
trying to replicate
[Music]
thank you guys for celebrating tasty's
fifth birthday with us happy birthday
oh yes
[Music]
you